So as you guys can see we are cooking up
something pretty badass and and certainly
a lot of fun that we are all excited about to
deliver to you guys um and I can't wait to show
you more you know I always thought that it might
be cool to hang out with Superman that would be
cool right I mean we're kind of similar in terms
of our powers our strengths our speeds because
look at the end of the day you never know
Black Adam and Superman could become friends
or they won't who knows maybe we'll see but before
I go I want you guys to help me out with something
it's something that's pretty important I need
you guys to help me get a message out to uh
to some of the other ones some
of the other DC superheroes
let's let Flash Shazam Aquaman Wonder Woman Batman
and Superman let's let them know something things
will never be the same because the hierarchy
of power in the DC Universe is about to change
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie turns out the
hierarchy of the DC Universe did not change or
at least change in the way that The Rock was
expecting he just revealed on his social media
accounts that he was basically out as Black Adam
Black Adam too will not be happening there have
also been a lot of interesting details about
what went down behind the scenes because James
Gunn recasting rebooting the entire DC movies
apparently the rock had been cooking something
way bigger there was a bunch of drama behind the
scenes I'll explain what was going on and what his
plans had been there's no one on this planet that
can stop me boom if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos James
Gunn did say that he'd be revealing all of DC
Phase One like the new DC Universe of movies in
January so we won't actually have to wait that
long before finding out what like the first batch
of movies will be in his new timeline of DC movies
with the new actors he already announced that
the new Young Superman movie is going to be a
big part of that so of course I'll do videos for
everything that they continue to reveal but in the
past few weeks you probably saw the rock posting
a bunch about the Black Adam movie in Black Adam
too so the first Black Adam movie underperformed
financially in a big way a bunch of the Hollywood
trades the website started reporting that there
wasn't going to be a Black Adam to now like
the chances for sequels basically had gone away
because the movie underperformed and in response
The Rock leaked a balance sheet for the movie to
deadline and made a bunch of public posts about
how the movie would actually be profitable
it would earn up to 40 to 50 million dollars
when figuring in toy sales and Merch this was
before James Gunn started to announce the end
of the Justice League characters in The Reb boot
of the DC movies just a little while after The
Rock has started to make a bunch of noise about
Black Adam too all the plans he'd made for the
future of the characters James Gunn comes out
and starts canceling DC movies and announcing
that actors are out they announced Wonder Woman 3
is basically canceled and even though he tried to
be very nice about the way he talked about it Gal
Gadot is effectively out as Wonder Woman they'll
probably recast Henry Cavill who'd been a very
big part of The Rock's push to bring Superman his
version of the Man of Steel back in the future of
the Black Adam movies announces they just recast
him as Superman the new Superman movie that
James good announced he was writing was for
a young Superman like Superman year two they're
doing the same thing with Superman that they did
with the young Robert Pattinson's Batman character
so one of the big linchpins of The Rock's plans
was effectively out don't cry for Henry Cavill
though he's moving on to a Warhammer franchise
he himself will be helping to craft to make as
many Warhammer mini puns as possible crafting
is a big part of that Universe probably an even
bigger part of the universe than actually winning
those games I already did a whole separate video
for the trailer he released for that so I'll put
a link at the end of this and down the description
below I'm very happy for him he'll announce more
for that soon after the year that Ezra Miller
has been having we all expected him to be out
after The Flash movie no matter what which is
why no one is questioning his fate like oh he's
definitely out my name is Ezra Miller and I am
criminally excited to be a part of the Justice
League Ray Fisher had so many problems with
the powers that be at Warner Brothers this
past year that he's been out for a while like
he was supposed to be in The Flash movie early
on but it sounds like when they actually started
making that movie they rewrote it because of all
the problems he was having with the powers that
be at Warner Brothers they already announced that
Jason momoa's Aquaman 2 will be his last movie in
the dceu as Aquaman and he's probably coming back
as a version of Lobo in James Gunn's rebooted
DCU that was all the noise that he was making
a while ago too like he's so happy to be able to
do what he wanted to do which is play a version
of Lobo and he will make an awesome version of
Lobo like we'd all been fan casting him as Lobo
long before Zack Snyder cast him as Aquaman he
here's where it gets a little bit funny because
it's still a developing situation like actors
are still coming out and saying oh I'm totally
not going to be recast Zachary Levi being Chief
among them like he seems optimistic that he's
going to continue with Shazam in the new DC movies
under James Gunn I have no idea what's ultimately
going to happen to me I think I'm in a pretty
good position I think we made a great movie I
think it's going to do well reasonably well I hope
so but again regardless of that if they decide at
some point that hey this is the way we gotta go
I mean them you know them is the breaks that's
how it goes and I hope that I hope that people
enjoyed at whatever point I finished playing
the role of Shazam I hope people enjoyed my tenure
in playing the role and that they come with me to
whatever else I get to go and do that's it okay so
I don't want to it's it's hard for me to see all
these random comments and and and like basically
lies and things that people were throwing around
online and not want to respond because I hate
lies I hate deceits I hate Injustice so much
um and so I want to set record straight by the way
so does James he's been doing this for a long time
that's why he's so active on Twitter because he
really wants people to know what's up truly and
wanting to set records straight and so it's you
know that that's why you'll see act action from
me or him or other people coming to defense it's
not because we want to get tied up on some random
argument with an Internet troll it's because we're
trying to help cut through all of the this random
you know deceitful banter that just keeps going
around and around because a lot of people who
are very good kind people who really like Shazam
or these other things are getting worried like oh
is this all falling apart is this all going away
everyone just take a breath I know we've seen some
characters some actors that are taking an exit
and I know that's difficult that's difficult for
even me you know what I mean I was hoping I got
to work with a lot of it but it's just not the
way it's gonna go down right now and I I think
you all need to whoever out there is still like
all drummed up and pissed off like just trust
that James is so look if you haven't watched
what he did with guardians which was a total Niche
property that he actually brought really awesome
life to and his reboot of Suicide Squad that was
better than the first one he really made something
incredible there he understands comic books guys
he understands World building he understands how
to do right by the Canon and also by the by the
characters and also by the audience and Peter's
there to be an increase an incredible Diplomat and
business person I've worked with him now for years
just breathe it's uh it's gonna be okay it's gonna
be better than okay they're also still releasing
the three other DC movies that are coming out
next year despite all the drama they want those
to perform as well as they can financially but
the plan right now in the DC movies is that like
90 or more of the DC actors are going to be
recast Zachary Levi's chances of continuing
are extremely small especially because all the
kids from those movies that are a big part of
the Shazam movies are aging up so quickly like
by the time they would make Shazam 3 they would
all be adults themselves so kind of defeat the
purpose of doing the Shazam movies the outside
hope now is that because they're releasing all
those movies next year is that when The Flash
movie comes out because they're doing a version
of Flashpoint already they'll just rework the
ending a little bit that will explain that all
these reboots that are happening this brand new
timeline that's going to start will be because
of Flashpoint just blame the flash for everything
sure is a nice timeline there really suck if
somebody just went and messed it up but the even
bigger behind the scenes news you probably also
heard when The Rock now announced that he was out
as Black Adam were all the plans that he'd been
trying to make on his own like he was hyping the
hierarchy of power in the DC Universe was about
to change for a couple years now based on what
was revealed turns out what he meant is that he
was personally trying to establish Black Adam as
the focal point of all the upcoming DC movies like
Justice League 2 everything his Black Adam would
be the most important character he even turned
down the chance to have Cameo scenes in Shazam
2 in The Flash movie when Warner Brothers offered
them to him before October before James Gunn was
hired they revealed that the current heads of DC
at the time were going to use The Flash movie to
set up a larger 10-year Plan Building towards a
movie version of crisis on infinite Earth they
were going to use all the upcoming DC movies
that were coming out next year to set that up
there were a bunch of special Cameo scenes they
filmed for that like Henry Cavill filmed the Cameo
scene for The Flash movie where they set up the
new crisis movie Ben Affleck's Batman also did
something similar in Aquaman to post credit scene
that he filmed in all the plans that The Rock was
trying to make it DC for his Black Adam character
were complete greatly separate from what the other
powers that be that Warner Brothers were trying to
do with the characters so there's this big tug of
war behind the scenes at Warner Brothers before
James Gunn came on and had the Black Adam movie
earned over a billion dollars at the box office
he might have had a chance of pulling some of
those plans off like he might have had a chance
of continuing James Gunn was hired shortly after
that though wanted to reboot DC movies in a big
way recast almost everybody and start fresh with
the new timeline slightly different backstories
for all the characters it just sounds like the
Black Adam movie underperforming financially
in a big way the rock having very public fights
with Warner Brothers in behind the scenes issues
probably with James Gunn too strong disagreements
is the political term they'd probably use for it
like we had strong disagreements about the future
of Black Adam inside the DC Universe that probably
just sealed the deal James Gunn was like I have no
plans for Black Adam in the phase one of the new
DC movies so sort of like the rock was engaged
in this bare knuckle brawling match with Warner
Brothers behind the scenes for the future of what
the DC movies would be then James Gunn comes in
as the ringer and just wipes the Slate clean is
like no we're not doing any of that we're going
to do what I want to do he's supposed to be DC's
new Kevin feige so naturally he doesn't want to
have to compete with a bunch of like really big
movie star egos in the future that's why I'm kind
of hoping that when they do recast a lot of these
characters they go with relatively unknown actors
the characters are so big you don't have to cast
like a really huge actor in the role for any
of these big Justice League characters there's
still a ton of questions like I said James Gunn
said he would reveal what like the full DC Phase
One of movies is going to be in a couple weeks
it sounds like they're trying to make Superman
the focal point of this new DC Universe not so
much Batman which is what they tried to do before
like 10 Batman movies for every one Superman movie
right now it sounds like some of not all but some
of the Suicide Squad characters under James
Gunn will continue in most of The Peacemaker
characters everyone click here for that new Henry
Cavill Warhammer trailer video to learn about the
future of his character and click here for that
new Loki season 2 trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys is the next one!